en principio aclarar la cifra luego de
las declaraciones del general director
del servicio nacional integral de
personas privadas de libertad mundo
moncayo ha especificado en rueda de
prensa que han sido 62 personas que
fueron asesinadas en tres centros
penitenciarios del país específicamente
le refería a cuenca como tú lo has dicho
pero fueron 33 personas de igual forma
en guayaquil
ocho personas en guayaquil y en cotopaxi
21 personas que fueron asesinadas en
tres centros carcelario específicamente
él hablaba de amotinamiento adén en
estos tres centros penitenciales por el
control del territorio específicamente
él expresaba que luego de una
investigación de inteligencia realizada
en los centros penitenciarios se detectó
que un funcionario presuntamente habría
estado involucrado en el ingreso de un
arma de fuego y esto fue el detectado
luego de investigar que se atentaría
contra los líderes de un centro de
penitenciario específicamente se habla
que son 38 mil personas que priva de la
libertad que pertenecen a 5 bandas
delictivas en este
luego del asesinato de un líder de una
de estas bandas en el mes de diciembre
ahora estaría peleando por el control
del territorio para así favorecer el
narcotráfico esto evidencia la debilidad
del sistema penitenciario del país
específicamente en general en moncayo
reconoce que el 70 por ciento es el
déficit de agentes penitenciarios para
el control del sistema de igual forma ha
reconocido el fracaso en materia
educativa penal judicial y de igual
forma también para financiar estos
centros de atención penitenciaria
gustavo no sé si conoce lo que han dicho
a lo mejor los familiares de las
víctimas sé qué va a pasar con ellos y
que ha dicho el gobierno respecto
pero básicamente lo que se pide es
información en las inmediaciones de los
distintos centros de detención
básicamente para hoy inclusive se ha
convocado a realizar una marcha en el
centro de flagrancia en la ciudad de
quito para rechazar lo que ha sido la
debilidad de los centros penitenciarios
y para hoy inclusive también ya el
ejecutivo nacional ha embarcado un
operativo de control de detección de
armas en las inmediaciones
específicamente los familiares lo que
reclaman es información porque se han
concentrado en los distintos centros de
detención de penitenciaria pero no han
recibido ningún tipo de información por
eso inclusive se espera una
concentración en el centro de fragancia
en la capital ecuatoriana
gustavo gracias por la información que
tengo usted es un muy buen día